congratulations on all the success
from this film i'm curious what does it
feel like
having you know being kind of a newfound
breakout star in america from this film
what's been weird or silly about this
new change
in your life what does it all feel like
um
i think it's great and probably the most
important thing for
from everything that i'm feeling right
now is that i can see that people
have been ready for these questions that
we're asking in a movie
and they're ready to stand up against
misogyny they're ready to treat each
other
with more love and respect and equality
and there are some beautiful messages
about feminism
how women should not be subjugated by
patriarchy how women should be
equal how women should have made own
decisions
and should not like make themselves
look in a certain way because of men so
i'm happy and yeah it's great i can say
that my life is
amazing right now because i also
because of my fellow bulgarians that um
a lot of eastern europeans has been
texted me that their hopes has never
been stronger that actually
things like that are possible for coming
from
a small country in eastern europe and
going to
like huge hollywood movie because
usually
there is no representation for eastern
europeans or
if there is some most of the time is
going to be for like if you
they're going to be the villians and now
we have tuta
which is a multi-layer multi-layered
character and
it's it's i'm happy that's excellent um
speaking of your hometown of bulgaria
you're a classically trained actor
you've studied at
academies in bulgaria and i'm curious if
any part of shooting
this borat film especially kind of the
improvised moments of the film
uh reminded you of training
if there were any kind of acting
exercises or anything you learned from
those experiences that helped you while
shooting this film
it did it was like training because
i'm trained as a theater actress usually
i mean not
usually uh like for real um
12 years maybe it's been 12 years since
i started
but i've never been doing improv
and most of the scenes in the movie are
improvised because we're with real
people yeah we have goals
that are following the script and the
story but you're there with some real
people and you have no idea how they're
going to react
you might think that they're going to
start laughing or they're gonna be mad
and they're gonna yell at you but
sometimes they're reacting in a way that
you can never imagine that they're gonna
do it
so probably that teach me how to be
flexible in the situation and how to
change more uh and of course all of that
because of sasha because he was like my
mentor and my teacher like exactly
guardian angel if that's what it said
yeah and can you walk me through the
process of
first meeting sasha baron cohen
auditioning for this role testing for it
what was it like to first get involved
the first time when i met him it was in
england uh for
camera tests because i believe that
they've been searching for
an actor who is not recognizable to be
an actor
because we're spending like hours with
these people
uh and the worst thing is that if they
realize that
this is a joke this is a scripted thing
so we had to make them believe that
these people actually exist
uh no matter that they're over the top
like they're quite crazier than usual
uh so i went there
in june 2019 uh for the first audition
and
he just walked me through how i should
keep
believing the character i should be
focused on what i'm saying
i should be serious because there is i
don't think there is a big difference
between comedy and drama because
probably the differences betw about the
script and about the problems that
you're
uh looking at because in drama things
the problems are actually really hard
and tough
well in the comedy they're smaller but
you have to like
you have to experience them as they're
something huge
so sasha helped me how to stay in the
moment
be in the character um believe in what
i'm saying
and concentrate maybe because it's it's
more of a discipline i don't know it's
weird but it is
yeah that makes sense um and what did
some of these screen
tests you filmed in england consist of
what did you do in them
i haven't seen them i don't know how
they look like what is it um but so we
went there
we were together for the first test
there was a there was another one
where we had to try the most dramatic
scene in the movie when
it's like the breakup between twitter
and borah that was the second one and i
believe so that
third one was when i was alone and they
wanted to test me
if i'm alone in a room or in a place
with some people that's pre-coveted when
covet wasn't happened so that's why we
were i said in a room
um if i'm alone am i gonna handle the
scene by myself because
when sasha is there he's gonna save it
forever
uh but uh so and i remember that
um some of them
advised me don't be like clean don't
like prepare yourself to look pretty or
to be
clam or something try to not take shower
and i was like
oh okay i mean i'm ready for it but i'm
in the middle of another production so
it's gonna be devastating for the rest
of the crew
in in in the movie that i'm shooting so
i made something
super smelly stinky with valeriana peels
um old eggs vinegar old olive oil
onions and i mixed it and it was
probably the worst smell that you can
ever imagine and i put it all over me
and i started like
hugging and touching people for bye and
they're like
okay this is not an actor for sure so
that was probably the last audition that
i went
and it was yeah it was maybe two weeks
before
i came to america and we started
shooting this
crazy beautiful world cluster yeah that
is so funny um
let's talk about how you approached the
character of tutar
what i found so interesting about your
performance is that we see
kind of different versions of her
there's a version of her in kazakhstan
then the version of her
kind of remaking herself in america did
you approach her
as different people or was she one
person going on an arc
what was it like kind of working on her
interior life
so uh thank you so much for this
question um to be honest
i try to to focus on who is actually
tutor because
board it is established character so
tuta being his daughter
should be somebody similarly crazy as
him
quite less educated even than him and
more primitive if that's the way to say
it
and she is believing in things that are
not
right but her intuition and her
how is it her intelligent in
biologically somehow is maybe faster a
little bit
because as example in the beginning of
the movie uh when today's speaking in
kazakhstan when i'm speaking in bulgaria
and i'm speaking
with some sounds some
letters that sounds more like romani
because in bulgaria we have a small
society
but we have dominance uh and i
was influenced by speaking more with
like ha
and ah so even when she's speaking in
bulgaria and she's like
well in the end of the movie if she want
to say
that day that day and it's somehow
softer i mean at least i tried to do it
same
as with the english because at the
beginning it's like how many other girls
are gonna live in hell with me
well i hope so by the end of the movie
she is more like
no i'm not doing it because i'm
beautiful as i am and her
i don't know but at least i was thinking
that well she's
uh following this path and when she's
here when she is
seen with her own eyes how actually
is probably the right version of people
to treat each other and
especially when she meets her godmother
if i'm able to say that
um janiece jones she she is having
how to say not catharsis maybe yeah
maybe she is having a guitarist with the
breakup with her father because
she is seeing that most of the things
that he's been telling her
are lies so she is going from here
and starting to envelop herself
so it is one person but is one person
who is
changing really fast in a good way if
that's the way it's said to the moment
when she's able to make her own
decisions
but she is deciding to support her
father
and maybe because he's finally showing
his love
that he is going to be there for him and
she don't need to live here the proper
life
she prefer to go with him and
save him because that's isn't that the
most important to love and to be loved
maybe i don't know i think you phrased
it exactly correct
um speaking of janiece jones um
what was it like when you realized in
your first interaction with her
that she was going to be such a positive
kind force for you
and not necessarily
a meaner or more intolerant person like
some of the people
maybe you were interacting with um
you know what i watched the movie like
three four days ago uh two three months
after the release
and i was waiting for the scene
and from the very very beginning when we
are entering this
house she is like
what is happening and i remember that
when i saw her for the first moment
and i was like okay this is gonna be
great because
we need people like her we need examples
like her we need
help mentors we need idols we need
people to be
like to be like her because she is the
perfect example of how
how important it is to be supportive how
important it is to give another chance
to people
no matter if they're crazy if they're
sometimes rude
maybe they're less educated to help them
to go there and to be
kind to be nice to be i don't know to
love
so i knew that this is important and i
was happy
of course i was sad because i think
until the last
day uh right before we release the movie
she's been probably still worried
about this person because she
she is an angel she has this huge heart
full of love and maybe that's that was
what i was
nervous because in the movie
we will all see her real self we will
always see
people's true colors so there's nothing
to be worried and something good
actually but i was worried that because
she is
incredible she's been probably worried
about tutor because
we shot with her a few months later from
the first scene
and she still remembered that girl and
because i wasn't there and i was crying
that can i go and see her can i go
here can i go and at least after
reaching and i was and they were like
no there are people called field team
you stay in your place
i was like okay i can wait i can wait
and i was waiting and
yeah i mean for me as maria is also
important that i met in my real life
a perfect example of um how somebody
that never heard about you
somebody that hasn't been
around you help somebody to
build his her personality and
um going through life with her and
like ready to i'm sorry yeah
it's just for me what's important
because because of her
now i'm trying to be a better person i'm
trying to
support people more because that's love
and kindness and support maybe
that's beautiful um shifting gears kind
of dramatically i know you've talked
about it a few times
the rudy giuliani of it all
that scene is so intense to watch
it's so scary to watch how did it feel
planning it going through with it going
into that bedroom with him did you ever
feel unsafe
what was it like um
so i was preparing myself from the very
beginning because i had a call with
monica levison the amazing producer that
we've been working with
with anthony heinz the head of the
writing
and sasha's long term partner
sasha and jason woolen are the director
of the movie
that probably there is going to be a
moment when you have to meet somebody
important somebody that is going to be
in high position so are you going to
be ready to do it and i was like oh sure
yeah let's do it
uh it's going to be cool it's going to
be
adrenalizing uh so
but i didn't actually probably realize
that it's gonna be that important
because i'm not american i'm not into
american politics so i knew his name
and i knew who he was because of the
terrible
date of 9 11. but i prepared myself to
be
like his biggest fan um knowing every
single detail
of his biography and
like a friend of mine was reading
stories about
him and everything about him until the
moment i was falling asleep the night
before
the day of shooting so of course i was
freaking out
um probably more because i knew that
this is an important scene for the movie
and for me as an actor i have to do it
and i have a
duty and i have to go through whatever
it takes
because it is in the script um we had
some incredible footage of other things
so that was the most important things to
be done and
i remember that my heart was racing i
was barely
breathing like this but i was like okay
relax
we were gonna get through this and sasha
was there and i know that
if something is about to happen
he will sacrifice himself and he will
save me he will save the production he
will save the movie he will
save the world i think that's sasha's
idea because all
he's doing is basically saving the world
through art
yeah and speaking of saving the world
through arts
uh as of days ago we've recently seen
donald trump get impeached again we've
seen rudy giuliani is no longer a lawyer
he's been disbarred
do you think that this movie and your
involvement with it
has changed the world or has helped
these big shifts happen
i don't know about that i think sasha is
probably more familiar because
i haven't been living in america for
such a long time i've been here only for
like two years
so i cannot say i mean we have different
examples in the movie and
people are different unfortunately we
haven't get
there united as much as possible that i
want to be
but i'm happy that because i remember at
november sixth or seventh um
when was when they revealed it because i
was living here in l.a and i saw with my
own eyes how people were literally
celebrating
and they were all together um
laughing smiling dancing singing on the
streets
during covet with with masks and for me
was actually
really impressive and inspiring to see
um
pamela harris uh the vice president who
who i remember at the fir at the night
when they um
elected her i remember her speech and i
was crying and i was like okay memorize
this because this is
the most powerful important beautiful
thing that you've ever heard
how i may be the first one but i'm not
gonna be the last
and again about the quality about
feminism
about how we're all human we're all
equal
we should not be subjugated by our
gender
ethnic background race religion sexual
um sexuality
anything just we are all human and we
are here
to to support and love each other
that's beautiful um speaking of messages
of feminism of anti-misogyny
anti-patriarchy
did you feel that those messages were in
the original plans or script for borat
too or was that something you brought to
it was that a
conversation you had with sasha how did
you contribute to that
i think that has been from the beginning
of the
moment when they've been creating the
script because
the whole team that we've been working
on i can call every
single every single one of them by their
names and i can
stand behind my words that i feel them
like a family and they are all
people that are inspiring that are
there to stand up against misogyny and
stand up against uh
women being subjugated by the patriarchy
because unfortunately
it's crazy but we are living in 2021
and there are still places around the
world there are still people that are
believing that women
are like somehow
i don't know and not equal which is
crazy so i believe that that has been
one of
the messages in the movie sasha probably
has a better answer but from the first
script that i read
it is was there it was there and sasha
actually
this is one story that i haven't
mentioned it such a uh session
to tell some point was about to become
like extremely
pro lgbtq activist feminist
that was the reason why i cut my hair
but their covet happened
um they were thinking even more
the script was evolving every single day
and
we left that line uh so it is being
there from the very first time
the feminism and the equality part i
believe so
but i'm not a writer for this movie so
i'm not sure that what i'm thinking is
exactly the truth i can say only what i
read
so yeah that makes sense yeah um
so that sounds like you had a plan for
this character that had to be shelved or
deleted
were there any other deleted scenes that
you
loved shooting that you're sad to see go
that you wish could have made the cut
we were talking about that like a few
days ago that
last year this time last year we were in
another protest
rich mountain i believe so and it was
like a big
rally again and we were so scared that
something might happen because it was
huge for this and it was important scene
and sasha was
in the middle of all this craziness uh
also probably i was i'm a little bit um
sentimental about that but we had some
super cute and funny scene
uh at one dentist uh place
where it was more of a physical colony
and that was probably the moment when i
was like okay just look at sasha and
try to be like him because it was cool
and it was funny
and i mean a lot of scenes has been
deleted
but i think we have probably the best
version of the movie
and maybe i'm subjective but i love it
i love it too um
you mentioned so the the kind of broad
silly physical comedy of this which is
so funny just
a universal language i'm i was so
curious watching this
did you have a plan of what to do if
either you or sasha started laughing if
you started breaking
did that happen during any scene that
you had to like scrap because you
couldn't
make it through so i was thinking about
that actually because especially in the
beginning
i mean jesus christ sasha is probably
one of the funniest people that i've met
in my entire life
but he is one of the smartest and
the most concentrated people extremely
disciplined so
even if he's saying something ridiculous
he has just
i don't know the the stoners face ever
and you you just
like yeah he is there he is this person
i remember a few scenes
when he's been repeating some crazy
things i couldn't stop laughing
and and after we finished the scene he's
like this is not in the script where
he was like i just couldn't do it i mean
it's it's so funny so
i i was asking him what should i do and
he was like
oh and started like exactly teaching me
and mentoring me
how i should go deep inside a character
in which way i should look how should i
because i'm
thinking more that the more you're like
doing
saying these crazy things and you're
sitting in a
home position it's harder to stay
uh calm just to keep straight face
rather than when you're
busy with something physically as
example like david and dance
because we we're doing this craziness
but we are dancing and our bodies are
already
involved with the action i don't think
about that it's funny that is ridiculous
and that is crazy
uh but when i'm as example in front of
all of this
uh no it is not the women
it's not exactly the same but when i'm
at the um the pregnancy christ center
and when i'm sitting there and when
sasha is repeating can we take it out
now please
and you're seeing the person looking at
us
and there are some awkward silence and
you just want to laugh
so hard but you can't and
i don't know maybe i was thinking about
something else pressing something
putting pressure over
some place on my body um but maybe
that that was something about that
that makes a lot of sense um i have one
final question for you and then we'll
let you go
uh what does the future look like for
you is there
another collaboration with sasha do you
have any other kind of rules coming up
or anything you're particularly excited
about
i'm excited cover to be over first of
all
maybe that's more because everywhere
around the world
now we have to handle this craziness
first
i'm reading a lot of scripts and i'm
having great meetings
and i'm not sure what i'm doing next but
i'm ready for it because
i want to work all the time um but
it's going to be interesting of course
someday i would love to work with sasha
in anything because
he is he is everything he is my teacher
he is my mentor he is my
i don't know every absolutely everything
and yeah
we will see how the things are gonna go
yes we will i
imagine your future's gonna look really
bright uh thanks so much for your time
it's great chatting with you
thank you so much